in 2016 bottled water outsold soda for
the first time in U.S history from one
perspective this is a great thing people
are choosing to drink water instead of
soda but from another perspective it's
brain dead that Americans are spending
so much money on bottled water and it's
one thing if you don't have access to
clean drinking water but this only
applies to 0.6 percent of Americans most
of whom live in rural areas despite this
96 percent of Americans continue to buy
bottled water resulting in the average
American consuming 47 gallons of bottled
water every year and much of this
consumption isn't on hiking trips or
vacations no Americans literally Buy
cases of bottled water and drink it on a
regular basis even at home instead of
tap water families who do this spend on
average wait for it 1 350 per year on
bottled water if you ask them why
they'll point to The Taste or the
filtration or the mineral content but
there's no evidence to back this up in
fact a 2010 study found that the
majority of participants could not even
distinguish between bottled water and
the tap water also bottled water is not
healthier than tap water if anything
bottled water is actually worse because
93 of bottled water tends to be
contaminated by microplastics and
speaking of plastics 86 percent of
bottled water gets thrown away resulting
in a 4 billion pounds of plastic trash
and at 2.5 million tons of carbon
dioxide every single year
So objectively speaking bottled water
provides no health benefit for 99.4
percent of Americans and its expensive
financially and environmentally
but then why do people still buy bottled
water
well the answer is brilliant marketing
you see the soda industry isn't decrying
over the fact that people are moving
away from soda because they're the ones
who engineer this transition in the
first place take a look at this lineup
of bottled water at first glance it
looks like a good assortment of
different bottled water but many of
these brands are owned and or
distributed by none other than Coca-Cola
and Pepsi Coca-Cola is involved with the
Dasani seal and smart water while Pepsi
is involved with Aquafina Schweppes Life
water soapy sparkling o and Evan and if
a bottled water brand isn't owned by
these two it's probably owned by Nestle
who owns 67 water brands around the
world
so here's how these three behemoths
brainwashed America into paying 16
billion dollars for bottled water every
single year
taking a look back bottled water is by
no means a new invention he first
bottled water plant can be traced back
to 1622 to the United Kingdom
from the very beginning the premise of
bottled water wasn't exactly a
scientifically sound
I mean the first bottling plant in the
UK was literally called the holywell
bottling plant
as you may have guessed it the water
promised to offer medicinal value
especially when it came to healing and
Rejuvenation despite its shaky
scientific Roots this idea quickly
spread across Europe and we saw bottling
plants popping up next to every natural
spring across the continent this trend
was simply accelerated by European
colonization and imperialism as these
superpowers travel to new areas they
were exposed to Nature that was
completely untempered with and this
simply got them more obsessed with the
idea of getting their hands on the most
natural water possible but while this
idea was quickly spreading across Europe
it took quite some time for it to catch
on in America in fact the first
commercially produced bottled water in
America didn't come about till 1767 or
nearly 150 years after the UK Americans
also didn't buy bottled water for some
sort of Miracle reason rather they were
just trying to get access to the
cleanest drinking water they could which
was actually a serious concern back in
Europe however Paul plans were simply
leaning more and more into the marketing
aspect in 1783 for example a Swiss
clockmaker named Johann Jacob schwepp
would discover a way to carbonate water
suddenly bottling plants had another way
to Market water Not only was their water
holy but now it was holy and sparkling
surprisingly this also took quite some
time to catch on in America it was until
1809 or 26 years later that the first
patent for carbonated water was filed in
America it seems that Americans were
surprisingly grounded when it came to
bottled water gimmicks like holy water
and sparkling water didn't really push
them to buy bottled water but disease
did as was the case in the 1850s typhoid
and cholera outbreaks were becoming
increasingly common which made a bottled
water highly appealing and given that
the supply of bottled water was somewhat
limited pricing went through the roof a
single pint of water cost as much as
1.75 adjusting for inflation we're
looking at 63 dollars for a pint of
water this was the first time that
bottled water started carrying a certain
prestige in America only the rich were
able to spend at 63 on Bald water so
bottled water naturally started being
associated with a high social status
this was the case for quite some time as
in the next 50 years but in 1905 the
entire industry would be disrupted this
year English doctors would convince
authorities to implement a public
chlorination plants a few years later in
1908 New Jersey would also Implement
water chlorination and this marked the
end of bottled water at least for quite
some time
foreign
the impact of water chlorination it
cannot be understated water chlorination
is considered to be one of the tenant
greatest Public Health achievements of
the 20th century and looking at the
numbers it's not surprising why water
chlorination destroy diseases like
cholera and the typhoida well before
vaccines were developed in 1900 there
were 100 cases of typhoid fever per 100
000 people by 1920 this number dropped
to 33.8 cases per 100 000 people and by
2006 this number dropped to just 0.1
cases per 100 000 people and even
amongst these cases 75 percent of them
occurred amongst International Travelers
But Not only was chlorination extremely
effective it was also extremely cheap in
fact you can treat a million gallons of
water with just a single dollar this
made it easy for municipalities across
the US to implement water chlorination
and within no time most Americans had
access to clean drinking water from
their Taps this quick quickly put an end
to the popularity of bottled water the
reality was that bottled water was
simply too expensive for the average
American and the only reason that it was
so popular was because drinking tap
water was an actual health risk but now
that tap water was safe to drink people
were quick to forget about bottled water
this isn't to say that bottling plants
quit trying to sell bottled water though
from their perspective the biggest
obstacle was price if they could just
make bottled water cheap enough maybe
they could convince people to buy it
once again the biggest Factor making
bottled water so expensive wasn't
actually the water itself it was
actually the bottling water was
traditionally bottled in glass so no
wonder it was expensive this was only
made worse by the Great Depression as
the average person had less money than
ever this was really The Rock Bottom for
the water bottle industry but things did
slowly get better in the 1940s bottlers
would start experimenting with the
plastic bottles these were indeed
cheaper than glass bottles but all only
marginally so it wasn't until the 1950s
and the introduction of high density
polyethylene that bottlers were really
able to bring down the price but this
didn't help sales like they expected
while bottled water was indeed
affordable it was still significantly
more expensive than tap water which made
it kind of a stupid purchase especially
when there was no objective benefit this
is very much the case to this day in
fact bottled water is one of the most
highly marked up items in the world
producing bottled water only costs 5
cents on average so if you're paying a
dollar for a dip you're looking at a 2
000 markup for perspective even movie
theater popcorn is only marked up
thirteen hundred percent this is because
somewhere along the lineup bottlers
finally realized that they simply
couldn't compete against tap water in
terms of price tap water was simply
always gonna be cheaper and if bottlers
couldn't convince customers based on
price they had to convince them based on
perceived quality and that's exactly
what what they would do
foreign
Ary Resurgence of bald water can be
traced back to a single marketing
campaign from a company called Perrier
Perrier was already doing quite well
back in France they were very much the
exception when it came to bottled water
as they were not only doing well but
they were exploding in popularity in
fact between 1946 and 1952 Perrier was
able to grow their sales 15x from 10
million bottles per year to 150 million
bottles per year what made their
popularity even more perplexing was that
they were seemingly doing everything
wrong they had stuck to glass bottles
and they were unapologetically expensive
at over two dollars per bottle but the
truth was that this was their secret
perier marketed themselves as the
premium water meant for premium
customers and in 1977 Perrier would
bring the same marketing strategy to
America they would spend a 5 million
dollars advertising Perrier as Earth's
first soft drink they claimed that
Perrier was more quenching more
refreshing and it most importantly more
natural this tapped into our natural
desire to live longer and healthier and
find the oso elusive Fountain of Youth
Perrier would pair this marketing with a
brilliant positioning they would Place
their water in the most elite
restaurants and hotels in New York and
Los Angeles this solidified the idea
that the rich were living longer and
better due to the water they were
drinking this completely redefined how
Americans perceived a bottled water they
started to believe that bottled water
was indeed better than tap water but it
wasn't quite enough to get the average
Joe to switch over you see Americans
were addicted to something else soda but
over time awareness about it just how
unhealthy soda really is started to
spread and the people would start
cutting back in the late 1990s Pepsi and
the Coca-Cola were witnessing the
stagnation firsthand as this other
Empire slowly melt away but that didn't
last for long as both of these guys
would swiftly pivot the water
these guys already had a Decades of
experience advertising sugar water all
they had to do now was Market the water
without the sugar
Perrier had already created a premium
image around a bottled water so all
Pepsi and Coca-Cola had to do was Double
Down Pepsi would launch Aquafina and
Coca-Cola would launch Dasani and they
would both strategically price bottled
water to be more expensive than soda why
was water more expensive than soda well
obviously because it was healthier these
two also had connections with the
basically every retailer on the planet
so getting their Miracle water into
stores was no problem at all
once their product was on shelves and
their commercials about Youth and the
nature were airing all they had to do
was wait
during the first eight years of the
2000s bottled water would rocket in
sales while soda stagnated during the
next day tears bottled water continued
to rock it while soda actually declined
leading us to where we are today
in the end the only reason that bottled
water is so popular today is because of
a brilliant pivot from Pepsi and
Coca-Cola they saw that their core
Market was declining due to health
concerns so they created new brands
centered on health the reality though is
that bottled water has nothing to do
with health in fact bottled water is
less heavily regulated than tap water
the FDA does not require bottlers to
disclose water sources treatment
processes or even containment reports
municipalities on the other hand are
required to send you this information on
an annual basis though of course no one
looks at these but at least they're
there this means that there's usually a
lot more variation regarding cleanliness
when it comes to Bald water one study
found that top water is pretty
consistent is generally having between
0.2 to 2.7 bacterial colonies per
milliliter bottled water on the other
hand had anywhere between 0.01 to 4 900
colonies per milliliter in fact six of
the tester Brands had 1500 to 4 900
colonies per milliliter so the idea that
boiled water is healthier or cleaner is
just a brilliantly constructed facade
and all the extra money you're spending
on bottled water is just going to the
pockets of our favorite bottlers
Coca-Cola and Pepsi and that's how
America got brainwashed into drinking
bottled water do you drink tap water or
bottled water comment that down below
also drop a like if you agree that
boiled water is over hyped and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community such as fertility ideas and
they consider subscribing and see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
foreign
[Music]